what the hell you know the expression a
man's man's man's flame narration wait
is that even a possible pun when it's a
female narrator pontificating about
standard male behavior is this
inherently a misogynistic sin or play on
a pedantic term that's used for just
this type of exposition opening to a
movie my point is that I've definitely
put more thought into this once in and
the movie put into the entire movie so
ass in it is you can't do anything for
himself at least politically correct guy
in the universe this is a hell of an
employee orientation my dad how can I
best describe that what you didn't see
was the moment just before this where
one of her girlfriends turned to her
suddenly while they were walking down a
busy city street and said hey tell me
about your dad strong male role models
honestly surprising Nick didn't turn out
to be a serial killer Oliver Twist
thinks this is a tough childhood hang up
I know Nick didn't have a traditional
childhood and he may understandably like
this picture a lot but placing it right
over his bed we're led to assume he it's
a lot of women here so are they just
cool with looking at the six-year-old
version of the guy they're countering
because in a movie with a lot of it's
pretty cool if I reduce you give you a
call okay here we go get ready for two
hours of this tall I found a grande or
at least I like to think so I could just
let these moments play on their own
without commentary and that would be a
pretty good commentary stop asking me
out you seem so stressed look I'm gonna
level with you
I'm not a woman I do like to think I'm
kind of in lockstep with the current
climate though and I gotta tell you this
entire movie is extremely uncomfortable
to watch especially these days and I
know the movies probably trying to show
me what it was like and is like for a
lot of women that have to go through
this but it's also asking me to
ultimately root for this mother so for
all that cognitive dissonance I'm just
gonna go ahead and add 30 sins right
here not only is my ex-wife Gigi
remarrying right about now as a matter
of fact what I remember movie has
clearly conveyed that it's around 10:30
a.m. Chicago time and it's obviously in
the middle of the workweek this really
the time for a wedding now get up there
already so we can break up the bubbly
this movie premature celebrations almost
as hard as it misogyny is over the first
ten minutes enabling between the fact
that there was already liquid coming out
of the bottle and the impossible court
catch everything about the champagne
opening is a lie
a completely unnecessary lie much like
this entire movie after an awkward
moment one or more characters grab an
alcoholic drink off a waiter's tray
cliche you're only 13 years old am i I
thought I was fifteen one of the laziest
movie cliches of all time is the showing
the mom or dad is so out of touch they
don't even know their own child's age
cliche Christ you movie for trying to
she's all that Judy Greer and expecting
me not to notice a lot about you Nick
about you to Darcy once Gary met Sally
what I learned there was that any
success I had was a direct result of the
team of people that I work with
regrettably though that team did not
teach me the proper way to use a
preposition at the end of a sentence I
know that five heads are better than two
five heads are better than two was the
marketing slogan for my freshman college
dorm Circle Jerks what when Sears
decided to go after women in their
advertising and said come see the softer
side of Sears Sears also if Darcy has to
literally explicate the value of a 30%
growth to the ad team I'm pretty sure
they're all ready for female driven
advertising totaled 40 billion dollars
last year and Sloan curtis's share of
that was zero how is that even possible
you're saying this ad company didn't
make a single ad geared toward women not
one not even one nobody panic
this is supposed to be fun this is
definitely what director Nancy Meyers
reassured the cast on a daily basis each
kit contains a more wonderful Wonder Bra
control top pantyhose and a Visa Card
the I know the rest of the pink box is
stereotypically female why the hell
include a Visa Card are women the only
ones that can use that because if so I
personally have a lot of questions to
ask myself
now let's check in on the woman's final
Sherman this super misogynist only
watches women on TV for sex appeal would
totally watch a men's gymnastics event
but not a woman's cot damn this movie is
insulting to everyone he monitors about
too much estrogen on TV and gets up and
then puts on a Frank Sinatra record and
this movie is over two hours long and
here's the moment where we're supposed
to fall in love with Mel Gibson's
dancing just like we will with Hugh
Grant and Love Actually in a few years
but even though Hugh Grant got a blowjob
from a prostitute while I'm dating
Elizabeth Hurley he's much more likable
than the actor playing this character
this smug motherfucker owns five
umbrellas also that hat req filed a
restraining order the next day okay I
think like a broad calling women broads
is literally the least of this movie's
problems and yet it's still a problem I
don't care how include lists about
current music you are in the year 2000
you do not bypass vo an apple and a lot
of s'more set for Meredith Brooks just
out of instinct alone I've been thinking
about why this doesn't seem like it's in
character for Nick to do all that once
considering he was vehemently opposed to
all things feminine is it because he's
drunk because he's such an asshole he
wants to derisive ly dismiss everything
all at once because it's a plot
mechanism to trigger some sort of
magical ability that will propel the
rest of the movie wait it's seriously
that last one a man waxing his body hair
hilarious and original and hilarious and
original and hilarious single most
conveniently positioned mirror of all
time what do women want
just being roll the credits here's a
sequence that wants to disorient you so
they put in thirty seven cuts in 15
seconds and it definitely caused me to
blackout my lawyer says I don't have a
case to sue but I can go ahead and send
the film however I see fit lawyers
Nik unfortunately survives this movie
manages to find one of the three days a
year when Lake Michigan is calm to film
this city approach shot the bigger
question is how did Alex not hear any of
this even if she missed the screams and
the pratfalls she'd at least notice the
power surge Frank you know I can't think
on an empty stomach I'm not even hungry
who said you were it's important to note
that 90% of the thoughts that women have
in this movie are about our supposed
protagonist I mean I know he's rich and
attractive and will go on to direct the
Passion of the Christ but Jesus Christ
there are so many things wrong with this
line but I'm wondering about most is
what the range is on Nick's abilities
he's all the way across the street but
can hear the door woman clear as day
that's the case he should be hearing
everyone right now rather than when he
gets uncomfortably close to someone do
you realize that I have an Ivy League
education and that running your stupid
errands has put me into therapy
you know maybe most women do have fully
formed thoughts ready to fire off as
soon as they verbally Express something
but I've rarely had an extemporaneous
insult loaded up in my head don't you
remember how long it took George
Costanza to come up with that jerk store
line get it because they're stupid there
are no exorcists in the Greater Chicago
area perhaps the most egregious lie ever
told by a movie it's okay you pay me
minimum wage because no advertising
agency in Chicago this large would ever
pay the assistant to an executive
minimum wage but nice joke out of touch
screenwriter what they notice probably
not if I didn't get class on anybody I
go with a fruit kind of fine suicidal
but but she's funny yeah so basically
all this movies priorities are out of
fucking whack sure I'm glad they took
the time in this fantasy romp about
feminism to dive into a nuanced
discussion about suicidality god this
may be the most offensive part of the
movie I'm not saying something so here's
20 more cents movie this place iured a
female creative director to be more
diverse but the pitch meetings are still
taking place in a room with multiple
pinball machines and everyone knows any
room with more than one pinball machine
is by definition a man cave in every
establishing shot we've seen that NIC
lives on the north side of Chicago
around the Streeterville area by the
John Hancock building but here he's
shown looking right at the Sears Tower
Koff Willis dance which is in the West
Loop miles away from where we're
supposed to be and then when we cut to
the shot of the exterior it's at 2,400
Fullerton which is all the way out and
being oak bark this movie has so much
wrong with it but it could at least try
to get the basic geography
correct right Nick also survives this as
Mel once again here's all woman's
thoughts I'm still over here screaming
that this is a ripoff of about the
episode yo oh yeah did you know that the
people that shop at Marshall Fields are
100% female how much was he going for
the lamp on eBay eBay if MIT are from
Mars and women are from Venus and you
speak Venusian the world can be yours
wait this is her response to this
phenomenon get out there and score some
Premium trim buddy no need to document
this extremely rare case of whatever
it's called how're you doing so is Nick
continuing to be an asshole or his movie
saying he's now redeemed because
nothing's changed except for Nikki using
his new ability to hit on the coffee
shop girl and humiliate his assistant
the director said let's have your
character eat an apple so you'll look
like even more of an assholes daughter I
don't get it first you throw Cameron out
now you want to take me shopping so I
can go to the prom with him yeah what's
up the bat I know Nick was trying to
impress Darcy earlier but Cameron is
still dating Nick's underage daughter
we're not usually like this on a first
date look everyone likes making out
making out rules but if you're making
out at 2:00 a.m. in Chicago near the
sketchy L stations I mean you think if a
guy could read women's minds and use
just that ability to manipulate himself
into bed with a woman and then the movie
later still tries to redeem that guy
well my head explode you were more
inside me than anybody ever said no real
woman after sex ever
sometimes movies go so hard and acting
real that they end up proving what not
real looks like as he's dreaming about
what a sex god he is how many different
ways can I find to say the film is too
long I don't care if he looks like mm
arrow Mel Gibson this motherfucker
should have been punched in the face
several times during this movie for
invading women's space this was fun the
fact that the women in this movie are so
easily swayed by the slightest bit of
attention from Nick is the most
appalling part aren't they making his
ass pay for like the last year's of
behavior did I say that out loud
dude this point if Darcy doesn't suspect
that Nick had a magical event brought
upon by testing out female products and
accidentally electrocution I'd be
worried before I came here I heard you
were a tough chauvinistic prick he wants
also this movie's biggest sin yes even
bigger than the uncomfortable sexism is
how boring it is just for the record I
don't think that's who you are this
romantic comedies hearing the thoughts
can see
take so fucking long to set itself up
that the two leads are only just now
beginning to even flirt an hour and 11
minutes in character takes off their
glasses and rubs their eyes to show how
long and hard they've been working on a
project cliche seriously think about how
often this happens in movies spying this
thank you
next oddly enough he loved the dress but
Mel was totally thinking about Pete
Davidson when he delivered this line
upskirting yes I know that's a mannequin
and yes it still counts
great oh god I need boobs this entire
over long dress trying on montage has
transpired without her having any
thoughts about prom or her body or any
other frame to eavesdrop on you a movie
boy you know boys and girls think very
differently about sex having the sex
stop Guinea preppy Italian joint while
sitting at the bar let's not make me
part of this NIC makeover or whatever
this new thing you're into is okay mmm
can I get in on that too she never had a
real relationship with anyone in your
entire life he looks devastated by this
but she's been saying like this to him
allmovie long there's no good reason for
this to be the moment her words finally
get through to him and affect change
other than the fact that we need to wrap
this up soon according to the extremely
subtle message of the movie you're
apparently turning into a chick you're
also checks notes copying be plot
storylines from Seinfeld and France what
is this old abuse charge
I see how did you know it was me I
didn't say this King magic now Nick can
hear thoughts over the goddamn phone if
there's no proximity restriction to this
cock then he should be constantly
bombarded with voices I see a couple
entering a bar called the back door and
I'm suddenly zapped back to the music
video for des jours backdoor lover I
Love You Man mmm the last thing I hear
skip skip
I said skip skip difficut I think this
buttons broken skip man it's like every
time I go to a goddamn jazz club there's
always a celebrity couple pawing at each
other and sucking face all so are you
really telling me she isn't thinking any
thoughts right now may I just say you're
an exceptionally great kisser it's like
this entire movie was built on the
premise of making Mel I mean Nick feel
good about himself this is the most
studio lot generic street looking street
I ever did see I bet they shot it on a
studio lock
ah sudden Oscar winner Marisa Tomei you
said that you wouldn't hurt me and then
you slept with me and then you didn't
call me for six days so that in the
world of me that's torture whoa there
maybe he's Trent from swingers and he's
thinking six days is kind of money talk
to me like a woman you think like a
woman Nick
admit it you're totally and completely
gay Jesus Christ does movie seriously
not know how gay works how I'm as gay as
it gets not content to offend and impugn
hetero man and women movie also appoints
its obliviousness gun at the LGBTQ
community Hey look low the yarmulke oh
no phone yes presented without comment I
predict no one will even know I'm gone
until the files start to build now that
it's crammed it's two leads together in
the least charismatic on string coupling
since the dawn of arranged marriages the
film remembers that suicidal girl plot
line that it dangled so carelessly back
in the second act he tried to be a copy
writer but got turned down so she got
stuck as a messenger fool turned her
down you did sigh sure Nick was a dick
about not even meeting with Aaron but
what evidence does he have that she'd be
a good copywriter does he dig the way
she phrases her mental suicidal ideation
cuz that's all the way up you know this
whole thing about penis envy
yeah not true duh it is and always has
been privileged envy it would not be
easier to run if you dressed sexier
mostly true except if you happen to be
running on boner Mountain emailed it
they hit a home run where do we sign
thankfully for Nick's psyche these women
take turns thinking rather than doing it
all at the same time will you come with
me someplace I want to show you
something I don't care if she's setting
up a surprise there's no need for Darcy
to pronoun game this hard you know how
people sometimes talk about a movies use
of colour standing out or being
exquisite or adding to the enjoyment of
the film they are never talking about
this movie this is the beige movie ever
hey wasn't one of the major plot points
of this movie the Nick needs to spend
more time with his daughter
I'm just currently living with him and
doing god-knows-what with her boyfriend
on his couch right now what are you nuts
what is this what do you mean this guy's
office is ginormous but watch ow as he
walks around his desk he has to pause
and go sidestep for a moment to pass
between his desk and chair my point is
the problem asked her would ham on this
set get hold to die she's home address
phone number quick as possible yes how
does Nick not have Darcy's phone number
even as a co-worker she definitely
called him at home earlier in the movie
is this sequence about I know he's
trying to find Aaron but what's with the
magical Chinese lady is the movie
seriously telling me that she's been
behind the soul in time also why is it
hearing her thoughts he hasn't lost his
ability yet and does he always hear the
thoughts in English does the magical
ability have Google Translate Katz the
cause of and solution to all of life's
problems you were thinking that just now
yeah really nice of the movie to give me
immediate and obvious proof that Nick's
lost his mind-reading mojo because
otherwise I'd still be wondering why I
sat through the magical Chinatown
alleyway sequence is there something I
can maybe do for you actually I came
here to see if I could do something for
you and this is the moment where Aaron
calls the police right right come on
Hollywood
give Judy Greer her due she deserves her
own sharp objects her big little lies
she's great what's the matters and she
had the prom Nick and the movie he just
had a sudden realization that there was
an obvious plotline that hadn't been
wrapped up yet I can't believe you're
going to say this to him in a public
hotel restroom oh honey I'm sometimes
it's telling that in a movie in which
Nick does amazingly inappropriate things
peering over a stall in the women's
bathroom to see his daughter doesn't
even crack the top ten but this movies
timeline Darcy said she couldn't move
into this place for another two weeks
that was literally yesterday and Alex's
mom is still on her honeymoon which was
also supposed to last two weeks and it
started at the beginning of the movie so
the movie had such a hard-on to get to
this final scene at Darcy's new place
that had totally destroyed the
space-time continuum I took advantage of
you in the worst possible way he took
her to an a that brothers concert we
shouldn't read your mind really dude
after that whole speech about your
growth and
needing to use life's cheat codes
because your love for her is real you
say this what kind of knight in shining
armor would I be if the man I love needs
rescuing and I just let him walk out the
door
holy brainwash role reversal Batman yep
I've definitely seen a lifetime's worth
of Mel Gibson eating face in a movie
whoa
listen to me
I'm only gonna say this once not a
chance hey we don't know this guy
there's no ransom will ever be paid for
my son
soon every American home will integrate
their television phone in computer and
my niece the daughter of my sister is
getting married my biological clock is
ticking like this and the way this case
is going i ain't never gettin married
[Laughter]
garlic larsen what are they a 1 exactly
baby wants to oh god I just looked at
his penis I'm sorry it's it's the police
come on admit it you're totally and
completely gay not that there's anything
wrong with that